what's your relationship with with mike
tyson oh i'm cool with mike that's my
boy i [ __ ] with mike dog mike and i
set it off for 4 20 this past year man
oh man mike is great i used to run into
mike all the time too even arsenio hall
show because he would just stop by at
the green room a lot i got bumped a
little bit for him you know where they
tell you you're gonna go on third down
because this guy's sure
that's all man you know it's mike tyson
yeah
um and um but mike's man i just i love
you know how mike has just
been able to evolve you know and the
thing about mike though that i love
though is that you'll get that dude
every now and then who starts to get
real comfortable around him and they
forget hey man he's a killer
like if you anger him yeah
he will f you up
yeah right there's that on his podcast
he was talking to some dude and the guy
you know yeah
and i'm like i'm dying did that footage
ever come out yeah duh right when he
actually sucks him oh he did yeah well
so the footage didn't come out
it felt like it happened but he felt
like i think he's gonna he's gonna hit
that you know what i'm talking about
he's like hey how do you know me you
don't know you don't know what you're
talking about yep i'm so glad that
wasn't me yeah because i would have just
got up and left
the guy's a killer dog that moment and i
know exactly what interview you're
talking about you can see his face and
he's like oh [ __ ] i'm crazy yeah but it
was like but it was like it was oh [ __ ]
the cameras were rolling yeah it wasn't
uh you don't really feel that way yeah
exactly was like no i really do feel
that way and you're in danger
yeah
i don't think i saw it i read about it
on tmz and i was like oh [ __ ] yeah i
never saw it either who was like i don't
remember who the guest was but it was
two dudes and then the one guy mike was
like you know sometimes i feel like a
piece of [ __ ] he's not no you don't he's
like what the [ __ ] are you telling and
then like
it got dark fat and the guy was just
like yeah
dude see what i'm messing with mike it
was funny i did it i did a
wee mass program with mike on 420 and it
was me
uh him this beautiful woman chef nicky
the dave chappelle's a private chef and
um and too short
and so you can man this is a fun meal
man yeah yeah and uh and and so she was
cooking up some fish fish and grits and
she put the fish and grits in front of
mike and he took a bite and he was like
this tastes like [ __ ]
and it just starts insulting the [ __ ]
food
right there with the chef in front of
the right and two shot and i are
cracking up right but you could just
tell he's kind of going off on his tent
he's like this tastes like my actual
[ __ ]
it's just he keeps going with it like it
just keeps getting darker and darker
right but it's like i'm you know a smart
person yo this is mike tyson he's
talking about his actual [ __ ] in
reference to some freaking creamy grits
right here you're gonna let him do that
you're not gonna correct him
just cracking up cause he was like yo it
was a anyway
i was too short even pitched a show idea
he was like man we need to start a show
called eating with bullies
where chefs just like take their food
onto a show with a dude who could
absolutely kill me
i give an honest review
to be like you're right
[Laughter]
i mean that's the best story man and
t-shirt
yeah we had a great time with that sure
we're gonna make that show man eating
with bullies man we gonna make that show
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude